[Music]
Today we're going to be making a
mechanical key for a 2010 Dodge Journey
using the Lei Pick CY24 for all Chrysler
a cut locks.
First thing we're going to do is loop
our lock.
I like to use lock shot. If you don't
have, you can use WD40.
Next thing we're going to do, insert our
tool. I'll pick in the make sure it's
all the way to the shoulder.
I like to go the opposite way. So number
eight is not on top, it's actually on
the bottom. So let's start with the
eight cut. See how it bounces here?
That's good. Let's go over to seven.
Got a bounce on seven.
Bounce on six.
Bounce on five. Four is tight, so
release a little bit.
Four is bouncing now. Three is tight, so
release.
Got to bounce on three. And number two,
release. Now you have a bounce. So let's
start working backwards.
Three
bounce is good. Four bounces is good.
Five is tight. So release a little bit.
It bounces now. So that's good.
Number six is tight. Release a little
bit.
All right.
Now that's picked. So let's go ahead and
read. Make sure it's all the way into
the shoulder so you get a proper
reading.
Number eight is a four.
Number seven is a three.
Number six is a one.
Five is a one.
Four is a three.
Number three is a three
and number two is a one. So, let's see
if we uh decoded this properly. So,
we'll go ahead and make a key. See how
we did.
[Music]
All right. So, now that we cut a key,
let's see if we decoded the lock
properly.
Works like butter.
Hello everybody in YouTube land. This is
Chris from Father and Son Locksmith and
I hope you like my video on Delichi
CY24 two in one pick for Chrysler 8 cut
locks. Please like and subscribe. I'll
see you on the next video.